[Musique]
[Rires]
quelles sont vos exigences en matière de
salaire
alors là je suis pas une fille exigeante
mais rassurez-moi vous ne travaillez pas
gratuitement quand même non mais j'avais
bien compris je veux dire je travaillais
gratuitement c'est juste faire une
insulte à son propre enfant vous voyez
ce que je veux dire il y a ses propres
compétences aussi oui à ses propres
compétences bien sûr je suis élevé
protestante croyante et avec une forte
spiritualité plus qu'une matérialité et
chez moi c'est des tableaux
Ikea chez moi c'est des canapés qui ne
coûtent pas cher chez moi c'est alors
par contre je peux avoir une belle paire
de chaussures je me fais plaisir mais je
ne suis pas dans la matérialité
[Musique]
pourquoi un kangourou s'appelle
kangourou ça peut paraître bête comme
question mais l'explication est dingue
lorsque les colons ont débarqué en
Australie ils ont vu un marsupiaux et
ils ont demandé aux Aborigènes de leur
donner le nom de l'animal les aborigènes
ont répondu kangourou ils ont donc pensé
que c'était un kangourou que ça
s'appelait kangourou mais 200 ans plus
tard les linguistes ont découvert que
kangourou ça voulait dire je ne sais pas
dans la langue des Aborigènes magnifique
c'est incroyablement ah c'est très très
drôle et femme
j'ai faim
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]